One of the things you should know is
that you actually die into your brain.
So one of the things you
might wonder is why is,
why is it the death evolved?
It,
it doesn't really make that much
sense from a Darwinian perspective,
right?
Because you'd make the presupposition
that if you could just stick around and
farther children safe for 250 years,
you'd be doing a lot better job than the
poor SAP who only live to be 30 so why
is it that you only live
to be 70 and really your,
you know,
your period of fertility is over,
say by the time you're
40 why would that be?
What's the utility of death?
And then you remember,
well,
the environment's always changing,
right?
In this chaotic manner that's
represented by the great mother.
Can you change with it?
And the answer to that is yes,
but only to a certain point,
which is why as people age,
they stay tend to become more and more
alienated from the current culture,
right?
They've,
they've adopted their
position of being say,
which is a word more or less fixed
by the time they're 25 or so.
Once their prefrontal cortex matures
and then after that the world gets away
from,
they don't have enough biological
resources left to constantly undergo new
revolutionary neurological processes.
And part of the reason is this,
you have more neural connections in
your brain when you're first born,
then you do for the rest of your
life any other time in your life.
And as you learn when you're an infant
and as you learn say over the first two
years,
what happens is that there's a plentitude
of circuits and they die off leaving
only those circuits that have a function.
And you think about that,
it's kind of a quasi Darwinian process.
And so what that means is that as you
mature and become fixed in your form,
you know,
to adopt your personality,
what,
whatever it becomes,
what's happening is that the excess
possibility in some sense is being
demolished by experience.
So the Tirana cull aspect of enculturation
is something that's real because it
makes you,
in large part what you are.
And you have to understand as well that
that's necessary because it's better to
be something in the final analysis.
It's better to be something
than to be nothing.
But you know,
we still have residual dreams
like those expressed by Peter Pan,
say who's the boy that never wants to
grow up because he doesn't want to attain
any final and fixed form.
And it's interesting
because in one respect,
as you progress through your life,
you're climbing,
assuming things are going well,
you're climbing to ever new heights.
But on the other hand,
the,
the direction that you're going
in constantly narrows as you age.
So there's a real trade off there.
And,
and,
and I think the existential angst that's
caused as a consequence of that trade
off is often real.
And I also think that adolescents and
early adults feel this most intently,
which is part of the reason why they tend
to rebel against social structures in
general.
You know,
the,
whether it's the military industrial
complex or the corporate world or
globalization or what have you,
is that you have these large structures
that represent the tier radical aspect
of social being.
And,
and it's no wonder that the fact of
those structures in genders rebellion,
it should.
On the other hand,
it's also no wonder that structures
like that exist because if they didn't
exist,
then people would have no
way of interrelating there.
There are social being,
and we would revert back
to the sort of hogs,
Ian State of war,
where everybody's arms are
around everybody else's throat.
That doesn't mean the
payoff is always good.